à moins d'une semaine du scrutin
réinstalle une affiche arrachée durant
la nuit il s'implique parce qu'il veut
du changement à
ottawaite comme 20% des habitants du
coin leur vie se déroule au rythme des
saisons et de la religion
il faut ramener la Bible dans nos écoles
dit-il et lutter contre le gouvernement
qui veut limiter les libertés des
Canadiens
l'horizon a perte de vue la terre est au
cœur du quotidien dans les grandes
plaines de maïs de soya et de canola
certaines idées sont bien enracinées
natale le chef du parti populaire
courtise ceux qui partagent ces
positions anti-vaccins et
anti-avortement
[Musique]
à la maison parce que selon elle l'école
fait la promotion de l'idéologie
transgenre
sont aussi déçus du Parti conservateur
et du fait que monsieur polliève ne
parle pas des dossiers qui sont
importants pour eux
ici en 2021 le Parti Populaire a récolté
22% des voix un record grâce à
l'opposition aux mesures sanitaires et
un candidat d'origine mennonite Maxime
Bernier veut répéter cette exploit mais
le contexte a changé
on est là pour gagner vous êtes en bas
de 22%, est-ce que c'est une bonne chose
écoutez la moyenne nationale qu'on a eu
la dernière élection 5 %. donc je peux
vous dire tout ce qui est en haut de 5 %
c'est une bonne chose pour
bleu tu peux mettre une balle ronde de
foin la peinture est bleue puis à wagong
et l'élection mais le bleu d'antan ne
veut plus dire la même chose pour ce
Franco manitobin ça m'inquiète qu'on
devient plus populiste quand on a nos
idées deviennent basées seulement sur
une idéologie sans défait monsieur
pollière dernièrement il va vraiment
apprécier qui sont désenchantés et qui
sont plutôt en colère au gouvernement
le candidat conservateur exploite le
même filon Brandon Leslie a refusé nos
nombreuses demandes d'entrevue mais sur
Twitter il flirtent parfois avec
certaines théories iron
de conservatif je pense à un moment
donné ça dépasse selon ce professeur
Pierre poillievre s'égare à vouloir
cueillir les mêmes électeurs que Maxime
Bernier
déjà alors il faut aller au-delà de la
table aller dans les régions urbaines
aller chez les progressistes tous les
modérés au moins les modérés sont pas où
se trouve pierre
le jeu c'est sérieux apportage de la
prairie tout comme la politique
carbone aliénation de l'Ouest dépense
excessive ici les libéraux ne passe pas
le candidat conservateur à la cote
mais son chef Pierre poilliev fait
parfois mauvaise impression alors
Maxime Bernier veulent tous deux séduire
la droite canadienne en colère mais le
contexte post pandémique a changé le
résultat de lundi indiqueera peut-être
si leur stratégie respective est
toujours la bonne ici Christian Noël
Radio-Canada apportage la prairie au
Manitoba